There we go. Okay, there we go. So this topic being real-world outcomes of bispecific T-cell
engagers and large B-cell lymphoma, or real bite as we like to call ourselves. So these are my
disclosures. And as everyone knows, Bispecific have been a transformative class of
medicines, as has been discussed extensively for relapsed or refractory large B-cell lymphoma and
other lymphoid malignancies. In 2023, the Real Bite cohort was created and set out to
collaborate with 21 different academic institutions across the United States to
assess real-world outcomes with the use of these agents. We found that compared with pivotal trials,
patients in our cohort had higher rates of advanced stage disease, impaired performance
status, and comorbidities that would have excluded 70 percent of individuals from pivotal studies of
these drugs. With 331 patients and a median follow-up of 14.6 months, the overall response
rate we found was 54 percent with a complete response rate of 33 percent. However, the median
progression-free survival was only 2.5 months with a median overall response rate of 1.5 percent.
The overall survival rate was 4.9 percent with a median overall survival of 7.7 months, shorter than the pivotal studies reflecting, again, higher risk population in real-world practice and highlighting the need for more efficacious strategies, as Dr. Barone has already pointed out with rapid step-up, as we'll hear for special populations like those with central nervous system disease and for an increasingly large group of individuals who needs to be treated outside of academic centers, as we'll hear also later.
We found that aside from progressive disease, that infection was the second leading cause of non-relapse mortality, and this usually was an early event. However, we found that even late events, infectious mortality occurred late after treatment, and sometimes when patients were even off of therapy, when they had completed the standard glufidamab dosing, these type of infections were varied.
They included bacterial infection, COVID, fungibacteria, and with various strategies used to manage or prophylax against these occurrences.
Also, we found that there were high-grade on-target toxicities, like CRS and ICANS, with deaths in four and two individuals, respectively.
We found that certain characteristics, somewhat unsurprisingly, were associated with progressors, including double, triple-hit histologies, higher overall IPI score, impaired performance status, refractory disease, and refractoriness to the line of therapy immediately prior to by-specific use.
Interestingly, we also found that in a subset of individuals in our group who had paired biopsies before and after progression,
CD20 loss was found in over 80% of individuals who were assessed with paired biopsies.
While this is a small subset with certainly factors that would influence the reason for them to be biopsied,
it is worth noting that CD20 loss was a relatively frequent event that was associated with very poor outcomes after that finding and after progression.
The median time to progression after the initiation of bispecifics was only 1.5 months among progressors,
again highlighting the need to advance these therapies not only into earlier lines, but with efficacious combination strategies to serve this difficult-to-treat population.
So, salvage therapy in this bar chart displays the regimens that were used, with chemoimmunotherapy being the most common strategy,
with these numbers appearing here on the right is the frequency of use of these regimens and in the bars themselves are the response rates.
The chemoimmunotherapy, again, most common and the remaining strategies being quite varied.
Interestingly, radiation therapy had the highest overall response rate, though presumably because it could be applied to limited sites.
Of course, there is no clear standard of care in individuals who progress after bispecific use and salvage is heterogeneous overall with low response rates,
which should inform not only studies, but also discussions with patients about prognosis and expectations after these treatments.
And to go along with that information, even less than in our overall cohort,
those who did progress and received any form of treatment after bispecific progression had low progression-free and overall survival that is shown here.
A particularly interesting subgroup of individuals are those who went to allogeneic hematopoietic stem cell transplant or CAR-T-cell therapy after bispecifics.
For allotransplant, we had 12 individuals who underwent it either as consolidation of a complete response,
partial response, or one after additional salvage therapy.
These generally were young individuals with good performance status and well-selected,
though among those who were able to make it to transplant, two-thirds remained alive and without progression with a median post-transplant follow-up of about nine months,
suggesting that this is a consolidated maneuver that can be very effective in a well-selected group of individuals.
Similarly, with CAR-T-cell therapy, there,
we had 23 patients who did this in various settings with an overall response rate of 43%,
almost all of which were complete responses after bispecific progression.
So also not a very common strategy, but can still be very effective in a very refractory population.
So to conclude, in the real-world actual practice,
epcretumab and glufenamab confer responses that are comparable to pivotal studies,
but somewhat lower in progression-free and overall survival.
Post-bispecific salvage, of course, is heterogeneous, with no clear standard.
And complete responders, though they are relatively few, may achieve durable remissions with a median duration of about 20 months.
So identifying these individuals is important.
And allotransplant, as well as CAR-T-cells, can consolidate and salvage individuals who progress.
Infection, of course, is a major concern, just like in other settings with bispecific use.
However, in the real-world, we have a lot of patients who do not have the same results as we do.
So to conclude, in the real-world, we have a lot of patients who do not have the same results as we do.
And allotransplant, as well as CAR-T-cells, can consolidate and salvage individuals who progress.